hello and welcome to 3abn today Bible Q
and A I'm Jason Bradley and I'm so
excited for this program because it's
going to be a little bit different it's
going to be kind of relaxed they're
going to have a a little more time to go
through the questions each panelist will
have four minutes for their question or
they'll get five minutes for one
question and I'm excited uh with what
they're going to share with us today I
want to share a verse with you before I
introduce them to you this is taken from
second Timothy chapter 3 verses 16 and
17. it says all scripture is given by
inspiration of God and is profitable for
Doctrine for reproof for correction for
instruction in righteousness that the
man of God may be complete thoroughly
equipped for every good work now I know
that you may have some questions that
you want to send and then and I'm going
to share with you how you may do that
you can text your questions to
618-228-3975 again that's
618-228-3975 or you can visit us on
Instagram at 3abn underscore official
again that's 3abn underscore official
and just send us a direct message with
your questions also you can email us at
bibleqa at 3abn.tv again that's Bible QA
at 3abn dot TV we have some wonderful
students of the word with us today we
have Pastor James Rafferty out of
California right now hey Pastor Rafferty
hey Jason hey Daniel good to be with you
guys we're uh cooking a little bit out
here but staying cool inside and looking
forward to be able to share the word of
God with those who've sent in their
questions amen amen it's great to have
you I wish you were here in person but
it's nice to see your face on Skype
so we'll go with that and we also have
Daniel Perrin in the studio Daniel it's
great to have you here you're a
wonderful student of the word yep thank
you very much glad to be here I love
that text you started with because I
want to be complete and thoroughly
equipped for good work amen amen why
don't you pray for us Daniel yes let's
bow our heads
our loving Heavenly Father
without Jesus we would have no hope in
this life so thank you for sending your
son to pay for our penalty of sin and
then give us the way to the father to
the throne of God and thank you for
giving your word of God as we come to
that today Lord we humble ourselves
before you and ask to be led by your
Holy Spirit in Jesus name I pray amen
amen amen thank you Pastor Rafferty
we're going to start with you on this
first question here it comes from Noah
out of Indiana nice Biblical name there
does Revelation chapter 1 verse 7
mention the second coming or the third
coming of Jesus Christ it talks about
the people who pierced him and also that
all the Earth will wail are these the
wicked ones who will witness the third
coming because during the second coming
all the wicked will be dead
that is a really good question Noah
thank you for that question let's look
at the verse Revelation chapter 1 and
verse 7. behold he comes with clouds and
every eye shall see him and they also
which pierced him and all Kinders of the
Earth shall well because of him even so
amen so this verse Noah is speaking of
the second coming of Jesus Christ this
is what we call a special resurrection
of those who pierced or crucified Christ
we know this for several reasons one is
it says that every eye shall see him in
Matthew 24 we're told that Jesus is
going to come like lightning shining
from the East even to the West so that's
how every eye is going to see Jesus he's
going to circle the globe when he
returns and draw all of those who are
righteous resurrected and Alive into the
air to meet him in the air but there's
also going to be a special Resurrection
for those who pierced him and you're
correct there are going to be those who
wail all the kids of the Earth are going
to wail because of him so there will be
Wicked people who are alive when Christ
comes who will be destroyed by the
brightness of his coming but
when he comes there's going to be this
special resurrection of those who
pierced him now we're told about this in
Matthew chapter 26 and verse 64. so
Matthew 26 and verse 64. let's just take
a look at that verse it says here Jesus
said unto him that is Caiaphas the high
priest thou Hast said nevertheless I say
unto you Hereafter shall you see the son
of man sitting on the right hand of
power and coming in the Clouds Of Heaven
so Jesus Promised the high priest and
those who are in the Council of the
Sanhedrin who were convicting Christ to
be crucified that they would see him
coming in the right hand of power so
those who condemn Christ to be crucified
would see him at the second coming
sitting at the right hand of power or
sitting at the right hand of the father
another verse that touches on this is in
Daniel chapter 12. now let's just look
at this verse Daniel chapter 12 and
verse 2. it says says
and many of them that sleep in the dust
of the Earth shall awake some to
everlasting life and some to shame an
everlasting contempt now when we look at
Daniel chapter 12 and verse 2 and
compare it with John chapter 6 verses 28
and 29 we notice that the sum is changed
to all when John when Jesus talks about
the resurrection of life and the
resurrection of damnation in John
chapter 6 28-29 he says all those who
sleep in the grave will arise some to
the resurrection of life and others to
the resurrection of damnation in
contrast in Daniel 12 2 he says many of
them that sleep in the dust of the Earth
shall awake not all but many those who
are resurrected at Christ's Second
Coming are resurrected to eternal life
but there's a smaller group that pierced
him that Jesus says will be resurrected
to damnation in fact in Matthew chapter
23-24 this is confirmed
Jesus is talking to Matthew chapter 23
about the woes on the Pharisees and the
scribes and he reiterates the same truth
to the religious leaders who again were
told this at his trial he says in
Matthew chapter 23 o Jerusalem Jerusalem
thou that kills the prophets and Stones
them which is sent unto thee how often I
would have gathered thee together as
children even as a hen gathers her
chickens under her wings and ye would
not behold your house is left unto you
desolate for I say unto you you shall
not see me henceforth till you shall say
blessed is he that comes in the name of
the Lord and then he goes on in Matthew
24 to give the signs of his second
coming so again we see the specific
rulers and leaders of the Sanhedrin the
rulers in Jerusalem who mocked Christ
and set him up to be crucified those
people were told you're going to see me
those that pierce Christ are told you're
going to see me come sitting at the
right hand of power Revelation 1 verse 7
is speaking to that specific fulfillment
amen amen thank you for that answer
Pastor Rafferty I'm just looking forward
to the second coming of Christ I just
want to make sure I'm ready just want to
be ready that's that's it well let's
jump into your question here it says who
is the John that wrote Revelation and
can we believe it is accurate this is
from Dana okay I want to know whether or
not I can believe God's word is accurate
the message is connected to the
messenger if we can trust the messenger
that indicates the trustworthiness of
the message so who wrote the Book of
Revelation of five times in the Book of
Revelation the author identifies himself
as John and that's the really the only
identification detail given there's no
title No history no no personal Pastor
experiences just John most Christians
from the earliest times have believed
that it is John Jesus disciple the
brother of James and there's not a whole
lot of Johns in the Bible to pick from
we know it's not John the Baptist who is
dead and there's no indication that it
was John Mark as the author chapter 1
verses 9 and 10 gives us just a little
bit more information listen to this
uh I John both your brother and
companion in the tribulation and Kingdom
and patience of Jesus Christ was on the
island that is called Patmos for the
word of God important there and for the
testimony of Jesus Christ so he is
imprisoned here on this island for the
word of God and he Bears a testimony an
experience of Jesus Christ the opening
line of the epistle first Epistle of
John first John that bears his name
listen to what it says says that which
was from the beginning which we have
heard which we have seen with our eyes
which we have looked upon which our
hands have handled that is testimony
that is personal experience here
concerning the Word of Life remember
John is in prison on this island for the
word all right and then go to the book
that the gospel that bears his name John
chapter 1 verse 1 in the beginning was
the word the word was with God and the
Word was God all right and so you have
the same theme running through here and
in verse 14 of chapter 1 The Book of
John it says we beheld his glory there
it is the testimony The Experience again
the relationship
and so the John of Revelation here uh
talks about the word of God imprisoned
on the island for the word of God and
for his testimony we see that through
his other books the John of Revelation
does not try to bolster his own
credentials by giving himself any sort
of title and there's other books that
that are not in the Bible that that
people try to put titles on to maybe
enhance their ability for someone to
trust them he simply calls himself and
Sean your brother
now those who study Greek grammar will
tell you that there are differences
between the way the Book of Revelation
and the Gospel of John is written but
remember they were written under
different conditions there in the in in
Revelation no one is there to assist
John in his writing and listen to
Revelation 10 verse 4. it says now when
the seven Thunders uttered their voices
I was about to write and then he's told
not to write it down in other words John
is simply writing things along as he
sees them as he hears them and in
addition uh regarding the Greek grammar
experts in New Testament Greek will tell
you that there's some Mis there there is
grammar mistakes in the Book of
Revelation and they say it sounds more
like somebody who is not maybe did not
grow up writing the Greek language but
is instead thinking and expressing
Hebrew thoughts in the Greek language
now whoever this John is and I believe
it's John the disciple of Jesus he has
the respect and authority to be listened
to as if he had been with Jesus so these
details indicate that it is John the
disciple of Jesus now can we trust this
book
like all scripture you have to put it to
the test we compare scripture with
scripture and realize that this
illuminates uh the Old Testament it does
not conflict or contradict it you have
to read it for yourself following what
what Revelation says in chapter 1 verse
3 which says blessed is the one who
reads and the one who hears it and takes
it to heart
Revelation began in Jesus at Jesus
resurrection it takes you through cycles
of Prophecy and you lay those side by
side with the Book of Daniel and you
realize that they're overlapping themes
confirm each other uh the accurate
historical fulfillment of the prophecies
there so far in Revelation lead us to
trust that book so you got to pray about
it say Lord Lead Me Guide Me Through
Your Revelation then read it yourself
amen amen but I love that amen we can
trust it absolutely absolutely Pastor
Rafferty can you please explain First
Corinthians chapter 15 verse 29 this is
from Felicia
thank you Felicia great question this is
a little bit of a difficulty in
understanding Paul some of his writings
were difficult to understand Peter
actually tells us that so let's look at
the text first of all in its context I
just wanted to lay down a principle for
us whenever you have a text that's
difficult to understand it's good to do
a study of it in its original context
that is the context the verse is in so
read read before and after the verse
we're going to read after the verse and
then also to compare this verse with
other verses that have similar language
or a similar subject this verse is
talking about baptism it's talking about
dead uh and it's talking about the
resurrection it's context Paul is
talking about the resurrection so we're
going to look for other verses that talk
about baptism death and resurrection and
first of all we'll read these verses
just to get a context First Corinthians
15 29 we're going to read through verse
32. otherwise what will they do who are
baptized for the dead if the dead rise
not at all why then are they baptized
for the Dead
and why do we stand in Jeopardy every
hour I affirm by the boasting in which I
have in Christ Jesus our lord I Die
daily if in the manner of men I have
fought with beast at Ephesus what
advantages is it to me if the dead rise
not let us eat and drink for tomorrow we
die
obviously Paul here is talking about an
experience that is spiritual he's not
talking about a physical death though at
the end he does talk about a physical
death but his primary focus here is a
spiritual death death to self and in
that spiritual death he points to a
resurrection from the grave in other
words dying to self living for Christ
leads us to a resurrection from the
grave now let's look at a couple other
scriptures here especially in the
writings of Paul because again Paul
wrote first Corinthians 15 and other
places of his writings will help us to
understand better what he meant when he
talked about being baptized for the dead
and this resurrection and dying daily
the first one we want to look at in the
context of First Corinthians 15 21 is
Romans 6. and we're going to look at a
lot of verses here so Romans 6 beginning
with verse 1.
what should we say then shall we
continue in sin that Grace May abound
certainly not how shall we who die to
sin live any longer in it or do you not
know that as many of us as we're
baptized into Christ's death
uh were baptized into his death
therefore we are buried with him through
baptism into his death just as Christ
was raised from the dead by the glory of
the father so we should walk in newness
of life
for if we've been United together in the
likeness of his death certainly we shall
also be in the likeness of his
resurrection knowing this that the old
man was crucified with him that the body
of sin might be done away with and that
we should no longer be slaves of sin for
he who has died has been freed from sin
very clear language here Paul here is
clarifying what he means in First
Corinthians 15. he's talking about
baptism and in baptism we die self dies
the old man dies we're baptized for the
dead and we live a new life we're
resurrected in the newness of life which
is a foretaste of the final resurrection
of the just so in First Corinthians 15
verse 29 Paul is talking about baptism
he's talking about being baptized for
the dead or for our old man and being
raised in the resurrection of Life
context of First Corinthians 15 is the
final Resurrection another verse you
want to look at here is found in
Galatians 2 19 and 20. notice what he
said here
for I through the law died to the law
that I might live to God I've been
crucified with Christ it is no longer I
who live but Christ lives in me and the
life which I now live in the flesh I
live by the faith of the Son of God who
loved me and gave himself for me so
obviously Paul here is kind of
summarizing it all up he dies and in
that death he has the hope of the
Resurrection baptism is a symbolism a
representation of the death to self and
the new life in Jesus Christ if there is
no Resurrection why are we baptized why
are we baptized for the dead for our old
man why are we baptize if there's no
hope of Resurrection from the grave
that's Paul's argument in First
Corinthians chapter 15 and verse 29.
amen you know I love the spiritual gems
that you just dropped because what you
did was you you taught us how to study
God's word line upon line precept upon
precept here in the middle there a
little and also pick apart the elements
baptism death Resurrection all of the
things that you see in the text that's
powerful I want to tell our viewers I
want you to know how you can submit your
questions just in case you missed that
in the beginning of the program you can
send them to
618-228-3975 again text your questions
to
618-228-3975 or email us at bibleqa at
3abn.tv again that's bibleqa at
3abn.tv and if you're on Instagram
please send us a direct message at 3abn
underscore official again that's 3abn
underscore official Daniel this is your
five minute question here does the bible
say that Satan himself will impersonate
Jesus in the last days
okay let's look into this question and
when we when we think about the time
when Jesus talked about the signs of his
soon coming there in Matthew 24 4
leading up to that he does start by
saying beware that no one deceive you
deception is coming and we know that
Satan is a deceiver he is one who
creates counterfeits all right listen to
John 8 verse 44 where Jesus is talking
about the devil or Satan says that he
does not stand in the truth because
there is no truth in him when he speaks
a lie he speaks of his own resources for
he is a liar and a father of it
in other words a lie replaces the truth
and so Satan goes about counterfeiting
and replacing the truth and we know that
Jesus is the truth now most world
religions really if you study them are
expecting in some way some great and
marvelous character to come they're
looking forward to somebody with power
who will solve or fix the world's
problems and looking around at the world
today as you see this world descending
further into what people recognize as
unfixable chaos people will become ready
to welcome a helper someone of power and
Leadership a miracle-working savior who
appears on Earth
so with that in mind we know that Satan
can appear with dazzling brightness and
to us to humans who've not seen Jesus
before all of a sudden if somebody were
to appear in dazzling amazing brightness
it could and would deceive people who
are not familiar with God's word
second Corinthians 11 14 tells us Satan
himself transforms himself into an angel
of Light we know that Ezekiel 28 and
Isaiah 14 both describing Lucifer the
name before he was called Satan as a
being of beauty
and so Jesus is the one who's the true
angel of Light John 12 46 tells us I
have come Jesus says I have come as a
light into the world and that's what
Satan wants to get in the way of to take
his place and so for an Angelic being
who can transform himself to appear as a
glorious angel of Light Satan knows how
he must appear the physical details to
make a counterfeit are given to us right
here in Revelation 1 13 to 15. it says
in the midst of the seven lamp stands
one like the son of man clothed with a
garment down to his feet and girded
about the chest with a golden band his
head and hair were white like wool as
white as snow in his eyes like a flame
of fire his feet were like fine brass as
if refined in a furnace and his voice as
the sound of many Waters you have a a
brightness and a beauty there
all right so that's what Satan could do
that now Satan Jesus will be
impersonated and we know that some have
already attempted to do that Matthew 24
verses 24 to 27 says then if anyone says
to you look here is the Christ or there
he is don't believe it then verse 27 for
as the lightning comes from the East and
flashes to the West so also will the
coming of the son of man be
um
this text here I think I skipped the
part says he will perform great signs
and wonders to deceive if possible even
the elect Satan wants to deceive even
the chosen ones the elect in other words
his deception will be cunning and
convincing and it will aim to the very
top not some small deception to those
who have their eyes on Jesus on the Lamb
of God Satan is going if he's going to
draw them aside he's going to have to
try to counterfeit that one thing that
they have their eyes on and that's Jesus
when Satan's very kingdom was in
Jeopardy he did not trust his his
temptation of Jesus to some other Angel
he came and did it himself Revelation 12
Satan the dragon he himself tries to
destroy Jesus as his birth he is the
Rival warning warring with Michael he's
the one cast out from Heaven Satan is
the one who persecutes the woman or the
church in verse 13 and he's the one who
uh tries to send a flood of deception
verse 15 and he's the one who prepares
for the final attack against God's
people those who keep the Commandments
of God and have the testimony of Jesus
and so when we get down to The Bitter
End fighting for his very existence he
is going to try to do exactly what he's
always tried to do stand in the place of
Jesus second Thessalonians 2 3 and 4 let
no one deceive you by any means for that
day will not come unless the falling
away comes first and the man of sin is
revealed the Son of Perdition who
opposes and exalts himself above all
that is called God that is worshiped and
he sits as God in the Throne of God
showing himself that he is God now this
is not happening in heaven because he
tried that already and it didn't work he
is trying to place himself in Jesus
place above him here on Earth and one
more text in that same chapter II
Thessalonians 2 9 and 10 the coming of
the Lawless one this is the one who is
against the law is according to the
working of Satan with all power signs
and lying wonders and with all
unrighteous deception among those who
perish because they did not receive the
truth the love of the truth that they
might be saved and so working real
miraculous
Miracles he will use scripture because
he knows scripture to set himself in the
place of Jesus and the character of God
is revealed the character of Jesus is
revealed in his law and so he will do
his best to take the place of God's law
and change God's law but we will not be
deceived when we have our eyes on Jesus
on the word of God remembering what it
is that he said amen amen seeing is not
always believing and we've got to stand
firm in God's word absolutely thank you
for that Daniel Pastor Rafferty this is
your five-minute question here and uh it
says yes sir is the mark of the beast an
actual mark on your forehead
that is a good question and one that
many people are confused about and the
simple answer is no now a lot of people
would say well you know the microchips
that they're developing now they're
going to put one in people's hands or
one in people's heads but you got to
remember that if it's a physical Mark
that can be forced on you without your
permission it's also a Mark that can be
removed without their permission in
other words someone might put a
microchip in your hand but you could get
that microchip and take it out the mark
of the beast is something more permanent
than that and so the mark of the beast
is uh symbolic or excuse me the forehead
and the hand are symbolic they represent
what we believe and what we do and this
is really significant when it comes to
this final crisis because the crisis is
about worship that Ward is used several
times in Revelation 13 and Revelation
14. in other words the contest in the
last days the conflict in the last days
is about the worship of God versus the
worship of the Beast I.E Earthly Powers
Earthly powers are going to enforced a
mark in the forehead or in the hand
through deception because we're told in
Revelation 13 verse 12 that he's going
to deceive the entire world that is the
false prophet is going to deceive the
entire world he's going to call fire
down from heaven he's going to deceive
them and dwell on the earth if you're
putting a mark That's literal in
someone's forehead or hand you don't
have to deceive anyone you're just going
to do it deception is involved in the
mark of the beast in the forehead or in
the hand so what does it mean in the
forehead well the forehead is where we
believe and the Hand illustrates what we
do our actions right usually our actions
follow what we believe but in some cases
they don't in relationship to the mark
of the beast you'll notice that there is
a contrast between those who receive the
mark of the beast and those who receive
the Seal of God the Book of Revelation
talks about those who are sealed with
the Seal of God in Revelation 7 verse 4
all the way to eight and also in
Revelation chapter 14 in the first part
of the Revelation 14 talks about those
who have the name of God in their
foreheads now again revelation 22 verse
7 tells us or verse 4 tells us that's
not a literal name a little writing in
the forehead again the forehead
represents what we believe do we believe
in God with all of our heart mind and
soul do we have his character reflected
in our foreheads in our thinking
notice that you cannot receive God's
seal in the hand you can only receive it
in the forehead and this is because you
can only be sealed with the Seal of God
if you believe in god with your heart
mind and soul however with the mark of
the beast you can receive the mark of
the beast in the forehead or in the hand
what that tells us is is that there will
be those in the last day
who worship God in a way that is
deceptive in other words they've been
deceived into worshiping God in a wrong
way and out of harmony with his law and
they believe it they've been deceived in
to such a degree that they actually
receive the mark of the beast they're
thinking their uh persuasion in their
mind is 100
in favor of worshiping God according to
the Beast the Earthly powers of this
world versus those who simply go along
with it they receive the mark of the
beast in their hand but they do not
believe in their minds in this worship
of God they simply go along with it they
comply with it let me give you an
example of this there are many people
today many Christians today who worship
God on the Sunday now the Sunday is not
a Biblical day to worship God Sunday
actually comes from a pagan holiday
Pagan worship of God on the day of the
Sun the venerable day of the sun it goes
all the way back to Babylonian worship
and came to us through uh Pagan Roman
the Pagan Roman hours but it was
venerated by Christians in the early 4th
Century under Constantine it was made
into a law and since then it's been
brought into the Christian Church lots
of people go to church on Sunday not
knowing that they've been deceived into
a change from God's Sabbath day the
seventh day to Sunday now as the truth
and the light of God's word is reflected
upon them they make a choice do I
continue to worship on Sunday or do I
accept the truth of God's word that
points me to the seven day Sabbath when
they make that choice they switch in
their mind and heart from The Mark of
human authority the mark of this Earth
the mark of the beast to God's law the
Seal of God and they're settled into the
truth of God's word on the other hand
there may be people who are not
Christians at all they don't even care
about Sunday or The Seventh-Day Sabbath
and yet when the cry Isis comes and all
the world according to Revelation 13
forces upon the world this restriction
of buying and selling unless they
receive the mark they go along with it
they don't believe it in their mind at
heart but they go along with it with
their actions this means they receive
the bark of the beast in their hand so
the hand signifies going along with the
mark of the beast you receive it in your
hand the forehead symbolizes believing
that this day of worship has replaced
the biblical day God's Seventh-Day
Sabbath so the mark of the beast is not
a literal mark it may there may be a
microchip chip or some literal way they
enforce the mark of the beast but the
mark of the beast is a spiritual Mark
it's what we believe in our minds or
what we go along with in our hands in
opposition to worshiping God according
to the word of God according to the
Bible on the seventh day Sabbath amen
thank you for that breakdown yes there's
a lot of guessing about this or maybe
looking at to see what Hollywood has to
say about it so I like that you take it
straight from the Bible for us yes
absolutely amen Daniel Proverbs chapter
12 verse 22 says lying lips are an
Abomination to the Lord why was it
acceptable for Rahab to lie does this
mean it is okay to lie to non-believers
are there other examples of this
happening in the Bible this is from Andy
out of Texas okay uh rahab's story is
reported in
Joshua Book of Joshua chapter 2 and some
people I have heard May perhaps
well-meaning trying to reinterpret this
very obvious lie in a way to say that
she wasn't really lying all right so
let's just get down to the point here
Rahab is not commended in scripture for
her lie or for her harlotry all right
neither of those things is she commended
for she is commended for her faith all
right Hebrews 11 31 by faith the Harlot
Rahab did not perish with those who did
not believe when she had received the
spies with peace and then James 2 25
likewise was not Rahab the Harlot also
justified by works when she received the
messengers and sent them out another way
so Rahab here she's a Canaanite and at
the time of this story she's a Canaanite
let me tell you about the Canaanites
Leviticus 18 verse 30 says that they had
abominable Customs Deuteronomy 18 verse
9 says that they committed the
Abominations of the earth Deuteronomy 12
31 they burn even their sons and
daughters in the fire to their gods
Leviticus 18 25 they defiled the land
and the land vomits out its inhabitants
so she herself whether or not she fit
all of these descriptions here she was a
Canaanite and she herself was a harlot
she is not a converted follower of God
yet in this story and so here this story
reveals her before picture when you
begin studying the Bible with somebody
you take them one step at a time and so
rahab's actions here her words reveal
that she is taking steps and where she
is placing her faith she is in process
so in Joshua 2 this chapter focuses
really on verses 8 to 14 where she makes
this great confession of Faith she says
I know that the Lord has given you this
land and she throws in her lot with the
god of Israel and then verses 15 to 21
is a seven verse long promise of
Salvation to her as she puts her faith
in God so she confirms this confession
of Faith then by taking action she cares
for the spies she appeals to them for
salvation through their God she advises
them wisely keeps their plans secret
fixes this cord in her window as
instructed invites her family to come to
her full home for Refuge she risks her
life turns her back on this past on on
the the people who are the Canaanites
and so it was this faith in action for
which she is commended like Balaam in
Numbers chapter 31 who advised Israel
sorry advised the midianites to to use
seduction and harlotry to deceive the
Israelites and to bring them into
Disobedience she could have done that
but she didn't at all and so in her
inexperienced very flawed genuine way
she actively demonstrates this faith in
a God who she at this point barely knows
now just because God commends one Act of
Faith doesn't mean that God can commends
every action that a person takes God can
be faithful to us despite our
shortcomings think of Noah think of
Abraham think of David think of Peter
they received Their Blessings not
because of their sin but despite their
sin and because of their faith and so
she at this point was still pretty
ignorant of the god of Israel but the
Bible tells us Matthew chapter 1 that
she married a man named Salman who
apparently loved her for who she was
despite her past God began to shape her
and she became the mother of Boaz who
married also a foreigner named Ruth Boaz
the father of Obed the father of Jesse
the father of King David and so she's
the great great grandmother of King
David let me come back to this right
here this great woman of Faith who
turned her back on her sinful people
says by faith the Harlot Rahab did not
perish not by Lie by faith wow amen amen
I'm so glad you got that question
because that's a very very popular
question that a lot of people have
Pastor Rafferty what will be the great
falling away is it to come or has it
happened already this is from Laverne
from Canada
thank you Laverne from Canada that's a
great question let's turn in our Bibles
to II Thessalonians chapter two this is
where Paul talks about the great Falling
Away now you got to understand the
context of what Paul is speaking into
Paul has written a first epistle to the
Thessalonians and in that epistle he
talks about the resurrection and when
he's talking about the resurrection
first Thessalonians chapter four he
mentions the fact that those of us who
are alive and remain when Christ comes
will not precede those who are asleep in
Christ but that those who are asleep in
Christ will be resurrected first and
then we too will join them in the air
from this the Thessalonians began to to
get excited because they thought oh
Paul's telling us that we're going to be
alive that some of us are going to be
alive when Jesus comes and so Paul
writes a second letter now and in the
second letter he clarifies that no I
didn't mean for you to come to the
conclusion that some of us are going to
be alive when Jesus comes let's pick it
up right there now Brethren concerning
the coming of our Lord Jesus Christ
second Thessalonians chapter 2 verse 1
and are gathering together to him you
see him picking up the subject here we
ask you not to be soon shaken in mind or
troubled either by Spirit or by word or
by letter as from us he just wrote them
a letter about this as though the day of
Christ had come
let no one deceive you by any means for
that day will not come unless the
falling away comes first so here's your
question has the falling away already
happened well Paul's talking about it
future to his time until the falling
away comes first
and the man of sin is revealed the Son
of Perdition note that phrase we'll look
at it again who opposes and exalts
himself above all that is called God or
that is worshiped so that he sits in the
temple of God showing himself that he is
God do you not remember when I was with
you that I told you these things and now
you know what is restraining that he may
be revealed in his own time
for the mystery of lawlessness is
already at work
only he who now restrains will do so
until he is taken out of the way and
when the Lawless one will be revealed
with whom the Lord shall consume with
the breath of his mouth and Destroy with
the brightness of his coming the coming
of the Lawless one is according to the
working of Satan with all signs power
signs and line wonders and all
unrighteousness and deception among
those who perish because they did not
receive the love of the truth that they
may be saved so
Paul is setting up for the Thessalonians
to understand that before
Jesus returns there's going to be a
falling away an apostasy is going to
take place that's what the word is in
the Greek and this apostasy was an
apostasy from Christianity from the
truths of the word of God this apostasis
movie was going to take place was even
beginning to take place in Paul's time
in fact in Acts chapter 20 29-30 Paul
warns about the fact that after his
departure that is after he died was
martyred and left this Earth that men
would arise up among their own selves
drawing disciples after themselves this
was the beginning of the apostasy this
Spirit of antichrist which is the spirit
of putting yourself in the place of
Christ the spirit of drawing disciples
after you instead of after Jesus this
took place as Pagan Rome removed from
the scene in 476 Western Pagan Roman
Empire fell and Christianity filled the
vacuum specifically the Christianity
that was conforming to and compromising
with the world exalting man in the place
of God leading popes to put themselves
and their laws in the place of God's law
this apostate system this son of
perdition system would continue on until
the second coming of Jesus Christ so the
development of the papacy began in the
early centuries A.D and would continue
to the second coming of Jesus and it's
called he's called the Son of Perdition
the only other place that phrase is used
is in John chapter 17 verse 12 and it's
talking about Judas
so there's no surprise that like Judas
we would see an apostate Christianity an
apostasy of Christianity conforming to
the world compromising the truths of the
Bible drawing disciples after themselves
putting themselves in the place of God
even calling themselves God and giving
themselves the prerogatives of God that
is the prerogative or power to forgive
sins and thereby taking the focus off
Jesus and that power continuing on from
the fall of pagan Rome all the way up
until Jesus returned the second time
this Apostle this this Falling Away
began in Earnest in the fourth and fifth
Century A.D and has continued to this
time and is Manifest in the papal power
wow what you said you said a lot on
that's good that's really good thank you
Pastor Rafferty Daniel if the wages for
sin is death then why after paying those
wages do we still need to be judged
whether we will see Everlasting
destruction or everlasting life how many
times after death will we pay for the
same sins okay
all right Romans 6 23 the wages of sin
is death now the answer to your question
lies in an understanding of death and
the judgment and the great controversy
and let me try to give you a very
limited illustration here let's say you
have a loan that you are have taken out
and as you're paying back this loan
you're paying interest extra fees and
interest all right but there Comes a Day
at which the entire balance has to be
paid even though you're paying these
fees of Interest along the way and you
may say hey I've already done I've
already paid though the whole loans
value back in interest but there's still
the loans value the balance the
principle that you have to pay back and
let me try to compare this we have Adam
and Eve in the Garden of Eden Genesis 2
17 of the tree of the knowledge of Good
and Evil you shall not eat for in the
day that you eat of it you shall surely
die all right literally there in the
Hebrew dying you shall die now their
lives were extended physically so they
could make a decision for the the
Salvation that Jesus offered word but
there was a final death that was
withheld from them for a while right and
that's what's coming in the future and
so in this life we have uh the
consequences of sin you know we got
struggling we got death we got sickness
you you lie and you lose
um you lose friends you lose trust you
lose peace and even when we then come to
the end of our life breathe our last and
we're laid down in the dust of the earth
I think of John 11 where Jesus talks
about about Lazarus and he says my
friend Lazarus sleeps the disciples say
oh good he's he'll wake up and Jesus
tells him plainly in verse 14 Lazarus is
dead that death is just a sleep from
which he will wake up each dead person
person who dies will wake up and and
that's one of those consequences along
the way but it's not yet the Final
Consequence and so when it comes down to
it God does not want us to live forever
in sin here and so he allows people to
die to rest in the earth now let me come
back to this I hope I'm making it clear
and the great controversy between Christ
and Satan Satan has attacked the very
character of God calling into question
all that God is his Justice his Mercy uh
his fairness so how could God give
Sinners the penalty of sin while the
case against him has not been finally
settled how could God say I'm going to
administer Justice when the the jury is
still out as to not whether or not God
isn't just according to the accusations
Satan has made a government based on law
would not execute and accuse citizen
without all the evidence being out there
and so God follows what we may call in
our court system due process
revealing the evidence of the character
of God and the character of Satan the
Judgment then fully reveals everything
so nobody will have any questions and
only then can the Judgment be executed
all right so those who died hundreds or
thousands of years ago have not yet paid
the wages of sin finally until the
evidence is fully revealed for all the
universe humans Angels other worlds to
say yes indeed God is love God is just
so how many times do we pay here's the
answer the unrepentant will receive the
consequences of sin after the Judgment
has revealed all uh all the thoughts all
the truth and they will receive that
Judgment at one time at the same time
after the Thousand Years while the
Saints are in heaven
reviewing all of the justice of God
Psalm 37 38 but the transgressors shall
be destroyed together the future of the
wicked shall be cut off in second Peter
3 verse 7 says the heavens and the Earth
which are now preserved by the same word
are reserved for fire until the day of
judgment and God is fair we live out the
one life that God gives us then we rest
in death without any Consciousness or
physical presence until the judgment is
complete and then only then when the
case against Satan that Satan has
brought against Christ is finally
settled then Jesus Rescues his people
and those who sighted against him will
receive the full final wages at that
time together and you can see this in
Revelation chapter 20 verses 9 and 10.
amen thank you Daniel thank you Pastor
Rafferty time is dwindling here
Revelation chapter 7 verses 1 through 3
states that the Four Angels who were at
the Four Corners of the earth were told
not to harm the Earth until the Servants
of God are sealed at what point does the
ceiling take place how can we know that
they are sealed
good question so the ceiling is a
two-fold work and it's to be
accomplished by the Holy Spirit as
outlined in Ephesians chapter one let's
just take a look at Ephesians 1
beginning with verse 11. it says in him
also that is in Christ also we have
obtained an inheritance being
predestined according to the purpose of
him who works all things according to
the Council of Israel that we who first
trusted in Christ should be to the
praise of his glory here it comes in him
you also trusted after you heard the
word of Truth The Gospel year of
Salvation in whom also having believed
you were sealed with the Holy Spirit of
Promise who is the guarantee of our
inheritance until the Redemption of the
purchased possession to the praise
of his glory Ephesians 1 11-14 so we're
sealed by the Holy Spirit we're sealed
the ceiling is into the truth of the
word of God and we're sealed when we
trust in the truth of the word of God in
the gospel of the Salvation we receive
the sealing or the earnest of the Holy
Spirit now it's an Earnest it's a
guarantee as we continue to be sealed or
settle into the truth we continue that
sailing process the ceiling is a process
that culminates with a final seal that
establishes us in a position that we
cannot be moved how are we how can we
know that we're sealed this was the part
of the question notice what he says in
Ephesians continuing on in Ephesians 4
25 through 32. this is how you could
know you were sealed into the truth of
your salvation by the Holy Spirit
therefore Paul says putting away line
putting away line that each one of you
speak the truth with his neighbor for we
are members one of another be angry and
do not sin do not let the sun go down on
your wrath nor give place to the devil
let him that stole still no longer but
rather let him labor working with his
hands what is good that he may have
something to give him who has need that
no corrupt word proceed out of your
mouth but that which is good for
necessary edification that you may
impart grace to the hearers and do not
grieve the holy spirit of God by whom
you receive for the day of redemption
that all bitterness wrath anger clamor
evil speaking be put away from you with
all malice be kind to one another tend
to Heart at forgiving one another even
as God in Christ forgave you that's how
you could know you're being sealed in
the very context of this verse These
verses it says
don't grieve the holy spirit of God by
whom you were sealed were sealed by the
Holy Spirit and we can know we're sealed
when we speak the truth when anger is
gone when we don't steal when we labor
with our hands to do what is good what
we provide for those who have need when
we don't have corrupt words coming out
of our mouths we know we are still and
bitterness and anger and clamor and evil
speaking is put away we know that when
we're sealed when malice is gone we can
know that we're sealed when we are
tenderhearted forgiving one another even
as Christ forgave us you know the world
around us is moving deeper and deeper
into sin and lawlessness while those who
are being sealed by the Holy Spirit are
becoming more and more like Jesus
they're law keeping their their moral
their forgiveness Christ forgave and the
final test of the Seal of God is going
to be the fourth Commandment which is
holy and just and true in the context of
his law according to Romans chapter 8
and this final special point of
controversy in the last days is going to
proceed the second coming of Jesus
Christ and we're going to know by faith
that we are sealed we're settled into
the truth of the Gospel of Salvation
from sin which is transgression of our
of God's law especially the call or the
part of the law that calls us to worship
God on the Sabbath day as opposed to
man's Sabbath the Sunday we're going to
know that we're sealed when we
completely Embrace or allow the Holy
Spirit to fill us with the transcript of
his character the character of the Holy
Spirit who is God himself and that is
the law of God in our hearts and in our
minds amen thank you Pastor Rafferty you
you know you started taking us to church
Daniel I want to I want to start this
question we'll have to finish it after
the break I want so much to read the
Bible but I have trouble understanding
much of it is it okay to read the clear
word since it is easier to understand
okay the Bible was written originally in
Greek Hebrew in a few chapters in
Aramaic most of us don't speak those
languages so getting it into the a
language we understand you you know for
me English how do we do that and there
is a range of ways one way is a word for
word translation in the exact order that
that the the original writers wrote it
which can be difficult to read sometimes
it'll look confusing the way that they
wrote Things a thought for Thought
translation tries to get the big idea
and makes some interpretations you know
you put things change some figures of
speech change some word order to make it
easier to read but then there is a
paraphrase and a paraphrase really is a
brief commentary and the clear word The
Message Bible the Contemporary English
version the living Bible sometimes even
the New Living Translation depending on
how they do it is more of a paraphrase a
person's opinion and interpretation so
is short answer you should not read the
clear word in place of the Bible but it
can be helpful alongside the Bible to
help you understand what you're reading
amen and we're going to come back to you
in just a moment so you can finish that
up make sure you stick around we're
going to take a quick break we'll be
right back
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3abian Bible q a for answers from
God's word
welcome back I'm glad you stuck with us
Daniel I know just before the break we
were going into your final question
please continue that and I gave you the
big extra here but you know just uh an
encouragement and I don't think I
mentioned your name but Sherry you're
the one who wrote this question and and
we're we're just excited that you want
to understand the word of God and for
each of you who are doing your best to
do that you you take this Bible before
you and you should know what it is that
you're reading and we want something
that's both accurate but it's readable
and the the more time we spend in the
Bible even if it's not the way we would
usually communicate or the way we would
write we begin to understand it we begin
to learn the language with which God
uses to communicate with us but uh
coming back to those paraphrases they
can be useful tools but you don't ever
want to replace your Bible time with
sermons or with devotional books or with
even a Bible question and answer program
they don't stand in the place of the
Bible but those paraphrases those ones
that I mentioned can be really useful
alongside but most useful most useful
whatever Bible you have chosen ask God
pray say Lord help me to understand it
amen and Pastor Rafferty give us a quick
10 to 15 second final thought
yeah I just wanted to touch on the mark
of the beast that was an important
question in Revelation 15 2-4 we were
told that there are going to be people
who got get the victory over the Beast
over his image and over his Mark and if
the Mark is something that is tattooed
on us is forced on us there's no way you
can get the victory over that they can
Mark everyone and anyone they want to
you'd have to be running away and
they're going to find you and put that
Mark on you so just a reminder the mark
of the beast is where we think and how
we go along with our actions amen thank
you so much both of you for your study
of God's word we want to encourage you
at home to continue to study God's word
stand firm on the principles found
therein and don't be deceived until next
time God bless you
[Music]
foreign